joining me now is Chad wool former
acting U.S Secretary of Homeland
Security and Lieutenant Chris olivarez
spokesperson with the Texas Department
of Public Safety all right Lieutenant
you're down on the ground what impact
will it have if we're diverting migrants
from all these areas into one place
what's that going to do
well Sean good evening it's going to
have a significant impact now you're
going to overflow one particular sector
not only that but we have to keep in
mind too that the Mexican cartels
control the smugging routes they're not
going to give up their lucrative routes
to divert illegal immigrants to a
particular sector there's multiple
cartels that are involved with human
smuggling drug smuggling so I'm curious
to see how that's going to play out I
don't think it's going to be effective
as far as when we're talking about how
the Mexican cartels operate in Mexico
how they have operational control on
that side of the border so I don't think
they're going to allow that that's going
to that's gonna they're gonna lose a lot
of profit off of that and the fact that
we're gonna now overflow one sector
that's going to straighten even more
resources now you're going to have
border patrol agents pulled from other
regions other sectors to not process so
it's not going to solve the situation
it's not going to solve the problem that
we're seeing on the border right now
yeah and to ask Mexico to to do this
Workforce is Bid enforce makes no sense
because to your point Lieutenant the
cartels control the Border you got to
ask the cartels to do this not the
Mexican uh government and you know the
cartels
um when they see this the were all
overwhelmed they can seek to your point
drugs and and weapons and other
paraphernalia Chad into the country so
the border with this policy becomes less
secure
well absolutely it's not an effective
strategy at the end of the day if you're
just going to rely on one thing and
that's the Mexican Government trying to
funnel migrants into certain sectors
it's a strategy that's just doomed to
fail it's time that the bite
Administration actually gets serious and
actually look at policies that work you
don't need to reinvent the wheel you can
go back to the Trump Administration or
you can even go back before that and
look at policies that work and policies
that work including enforcing the law
along that border holding individuals
accountable who choose and knowingly
choose to break the law it's also going
after the cartel so there's a number of
things that the bite Administration can
do it takes leadership it takes will it
takes the ability to make some hard
choices here and you're going to make
some people upset but that's what it
takes to actually enforce border
security and making sure that we're
protecting those communities in South
Texas and all along that all along that
border you know I think the point though
Chad is this Administration is not going
to do that you know they want an open
border I know the policy could work you
saw it work when you were there and
Donald Trump wasn't office and I guess
you know Lieutenant
um so we all if Joe Biden is not going
to do it we do look to Texas and you
know should the governor declare that
this is an invasion that he sends more
troops down National Guard down to the
border to make sure we secure it build
more fencing more wool is there more
that Texas Texas can do to secure the
Border doing the job that Joe Biden
isn't doing himself
well of course there is I mean we've
been doing it from day one ever since
last year and just most recently the
governor deployed 400 additional
National Guard soldiers to El Paso and
they were actually able to put up razor
wire and shut down that area where we're
seeing the massive groups that we're
coming across but now all that does is
funnel those illegal immigrants to
another area of the border and of course
you know border patrol they're
instructed by the federal government to
allow them in and because of that we
continue to reward incentivize illegal
immigration that's why this is not going
to stop and to Chad's point I mean prior
to 2021 we saw what was working we had
the record the lowest number of
encounters and the highest number of
enforcement action on our border and
that's been completely dismantled and
that undermines immigration enforcement
and as long as we continue to
incentivize illegal immigration we're
going to continue to have this collapse
on our border
yeah no doubt about that Chad you know
some Democrats are finally calling by
now over his policy watch
I share your your feeling of frustration
and the need for more urgency and I want
to see that uh starting with the White
House should the president be here do
you think I think absolutely the
President should be here and I think
um everyone should be here you know Chad
I'm happy that Democrats are now calling
out Joe Biden but I wonder why is it
taking so long for Democrats especially
on the border in Texas to call out Joe
Biden for this failed policy
well I agree with you where have they
been for the last 23 months this is not
a crisis that happened overnight it's
not a crisis that happened last week or
even last month this has really since
been since been day one of this
Administration that we have seen these
numbers increase dramatically and we've
seen this crisis day in and day out for
the last 23 months look I'm glad you've
got some Democrats that are saying you
know saying these things I don't think
they can ignore reality any longer and I
think they are they are realizing that
there is no strategy in place there is
no plan in place there is no change in
tactics the strategy has failed they
have tried it for 23 months almost two
years now it has failed they need to
recognize that and they need to change
strategy but they're not and I think you
have a number of Democrats that are
speaking out saying look I I this is
concerning it's why they all almost
universally don't want title 42 to go
away even though it's a public health
emergency it's the only thing that's
keeping immigration in the border secure
they know that and that's why they are
for title 42 and that's why Joe Biden
wants to end it Chad and Lieutenant
oliveiras thank you for joining me
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else